they've survived the violence in Sudan
in Chad another struggle begins
eight organizations say they were not
prepared for the humanitarian crisis to
become this big this quickly
people arrive with gunshot wounds one
woman gave birth in this open field they
tell us men boys even young girls were
taken prisoner along the way
but for some the journey from westar4
was too much
the war has scattered people the baby
was sick and she died on the way here
the baby's mother left her here to
search for her other children
her family and Chad is seeing her for
the first time they don't even know if
she had a name
those who make it try to find friends
and relatives
there are reunions but precious few
[Music]
car is here they are doing assessments
and someone told us that they have never
seen it this bad that they are
incredibly underfunded they do not have
enough money to help people here with
anything
and that the International Community
simply doesn't care enough about this
crisis that it is just pure chaos
some arrive only to bury the children
they fled here to save
in the smallest Graves two girls and a
little boy none older than three
their fathers did not make it across
he died from weakness because they had
no food and their mothers didn't have
the milk to feed them they're dead
because of hunger caused by the war and
not just them probably the numbers will
go up in the next few days
they tell us their government their
country and the world have abandoned
them their situation they say is
hopeless Zain Bas Ravi al-jazeera Audrey
on the chat Sudan border